yeah
not much to fight for here you're right
Peter King D2 King C1 and King B2 that's
gonna be the winning idea once you win
B3 you are three pawns up
yes and basically white I mean black can
do nothing against White's construction
yeah the only vulnerable Pawn F4 is
protecting by the Knight which before
took excellent kill of the people Knight
protects the F4 pawn and white skin is
just slowly
walking towards the beastly Pawn
that's it that there is literally
nothing to fight for every move you lose
upon King D7 Knight C5 check Knight C5
check King D2
at this point it doesn't matter who's
sitting across from you if it's Magnus
or a three-headed dragon
and to convert any end game against
Magnus Carlson in so smooth a fashion is
also what impressed me it's not just the
fact that he sees this opportunity but
also that he traded Rooks which was a
very mature decision it was a hard
decision because he left Magnus with
this outside passer on B5 and Vincent
realized that even though his own Pawn
majority was less Advanced that it would
ultimately decide the game and it just
has a historical moment Vincent kymer
defeats Magnus Carlson the highest rated
player in the world in chess history in
the first game of their mini-match what
a huge moment Peter for the German
youngster yeah absolutely I mean uh
this this means a lot but as you said no
time to celebrate it's clear that
magnusville bonds I mean try to bounce
back tomorrow with all his energy all
his efforts